okay so we've got our awesome prototype
and we've got our excitement and we know
what information we want to get out of
the user research process we're all
ready to go the only problem is we
haven't found any users to test with yet
where do we find those users remember
the idea of circles of feedback in this
version of the app we're going to target
the circle that is closest to you that
means friends family or coworkers
however we don't want just anyone some
people don't always give good feedback
for instance my dad will pretty much
always tell me that anything I build is
great so I can't rely on him for
feedback on what's wrong with an app
idea also people who are too technical
or design focused will often delve
straight into solutions without giving
you their raw reactions this means their
feedback is often less valuable at this
stage the ideal person to ask for
feedback on the app concept and
execution is someone close to you who
does not build at or design apps on
their own you work in an office HR
marketing can often give really good
user feedback if you don't you can often
find a family member or friend who is
not in the business of building apps oh
and one more thing be sure this is
someone you have easy access to
prototyping is a fast process and you'll
want to get feedback as soon as possible
ideally this is someone you can talk to
later today a family member in a faraway
land is not going to be quite as helpful
as your neighbor who you can talk to now